[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Welcome to Talks
at Google in Cambridge, Mass.
My grandmother grew up in a
small village outside of Rome.
If there were no tomatoes in the
garden, you had the zucchini.
If you wanted eggs for
breakfast, check with the hen.
Today, we have access to
whatever foods we want,
when we want, but
what is the trade off?
Is the convenience worth
it if we are putting our
and our children's
health in jeopardy?
Why has there been a spike in
chronic illness in our youth,
and what can we
do to prevent it?
In her book, "The
Dirt Cure," Dr. Maya
asks these questions
and many more
regarding allergies,
medications, and the foods
we eat, and how they will affect
our generation and the next.
It reveals to us why
dirt is the new healthy.
With that, please help
me welcome Dr. Maya
Shetreat-Klein.
[APPLAUSE]
MAYA SHETREAT-KLEIN: Thank you.
Hello.
All right.
So I'm going to be talking
about something pretty
low tech in one of the
highly technological places
in the country.
And I want to start
for a minute just
to ask you to close your
eyes, and I want you
to picture what a healthy
person looks like.
It could be a
healthy kid, could be
a healthy adult. Just close
your eyes and kind of picture
that for a second.
And open your eyes, and can you
tell me what kind of qualities
you noticed in the person
in your imagination,
the healthy person?
Yell it out.
AUDIENCE: Skin tone.
MAYA SHETREAT-KLEIN: Skin tone.
AUDIENCE: Smiling.
MAYA SHETREAT-KLEIN:
Smiling, OK.
What?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MAYA SHETREAT-KLEIN:
Energetic, great.
OK, so the reason that
I ask this question
is because we spend a lot of
time thinking about disease
and sickness, and I think
we've forgotten a little bit
what healthy really
looks like and what
we're kind of aiming for.
And you know, it's funny.
When I talk to
doctors in particular,
they're often kind of
stumped by this question
because for them, health is
often the absence of disease.
You're not sick.
You're healthy.
But I don't actually agree
that that's the case,
and there's this
attitude in medicine
you should be happy
you're not dead.
That's kind of where--
however you want to give birth
or however you want to--
whatever kind of intervention
you've had in the hospital,
if you're alive, you're happy.
So that's not always
true, and I think
health is more than
the absence of disease,
and it's not just a reflection
of whether we face stressors
or show symptoms, right?
People will come to me and
say, oh, I'm so healthy.
I never get sick.
I never have a cold, or my
kid never gets ear infection.
Yes, great.
That can be very good, but
that's not all that health is,
and it's not simply lab
results or other kinds
of scientific measures.
I get a lot of that when
I talk to doctors too.
So health really
reflects the relationship
between your internal and
your external terrain, OK?
So health is
really-- it's fluid.
It's a relationship.
And it's something
that is always in flux.
So health really
manifests as resilience,
and resilience is the
ability to bounce back.
So really, it's not so
much the stressors, right?
Stressors are inevitable.
And actually, they're
necessary to build resilience.
If you don't have
those stressors,
then it's much less
likely that you're going
to be resilient and healthy.
Now, chronic disease is rising
in children and in adults,
and I like this little
cartoon because when I first
started practicing
medicine, I had
a lot of kids who came to me.
So I treat both kids and
adults, but mostly kids.
And I kept finding that kids
were coming in on three, four,
five, six different
prescription medications.
Over the course of
the year, they'd
be on their asthma medication.
They'd be on their allergy meds.
They'd have their
steroids for their skin.
They'd be getting maybe
Ritalin, or maybe they'd
be getting an
antidepressant for anxiety.
There was a long list.
They'd get their Miralax
for constipation, right?
So there's always
a lot going on even
with kids, let
alone adults, right?
So chronic disease
actually, I believe, results
from a lack of resilience, and
there's science to show this.
Sometimes I say
things that people
have a hard time
believing, so I like
to have lots of
scientific references
so you can always see that
I'm not just making it up
and it's not just
a theory of my own.
This is from a journal
called "Mitochondrion."
Bob [INAUDIBLE], who is
an amazing mitochondrial
researcher in California, who
talks about the cell danger
response-- and the
cell danger response
is this metabolic response
that protects cells and hosts
from harm.
And basically, any kind
of stressor-- chemical,
physical, biologic
stressors that
exceed the cellular
capacity for homeostasis,
to stay in balance, triggers
this cell danger response,
and the cell starts to
function differently,
kind of in defensive mode.
And it's hard when
you're in defensive mode
to function optimally, right?
Because you're not going to
be-- you're not creative.
You're not-- I mean,
think about it.
If you're in a
defensive state, you
don't have all your resources
to dedicate to moving forward
and to progressing.
So after the danger's been
eliminated or neutralized,
then there's a
choreographed sequence
of these anti-inflammatory
and regenerative pathways
that actually reverse
the cell danger response
and allow healing.
But sometimes the cell danger
response persists abnormally,
and then whole body metabolism,
including the gut microbiome,
are disturbed and it can
lead to multiple organ system
impairment, and behavior
changes, and chronic illness.
This is straight from the paper.
And this is just an example
of that in a neuron.
So we have these microglia.
And microglia are these
nurse cells in the brain.
We have three microglia for
every one neuron in the brain.
So they're pretty important.
We've ignored them
for a long time.
We do that in medicine, just
kind of say, oh, you're extra.
No, not so much.
They're actually nurse cells and
they take care of our neurons
when things are going nicely.
Then when there's
this stressor, we
have that cell danger response,
the microglia become mama bear.
They go from being nurturing,
nursing to being kind of ooh,
aggressive, releasing all
these inflammatory cytokines,
chemokines, and excitotoxins.
And it causes a lot of
disruption for the neuron.
So that is called
microglial activation.
And it's basically implicated
in all different kinds
of neurologic conditions,
from ADHD and autism,
to Tourette's, to seizures,
to Alzheimer's, Parkinson's--
basically you name the
chronic neurologic illness,
microglial activation
is implicated.
And there's a
whole, what we call,
immunoexcitotoxicity cascade
that happens in that process.
And then if the cell
danger response dissipates,
then these microglia
go back to releasing
growth factors and
anti-inflammatory cytokines
that help regenerate the
neurons that were damaged,
and become the
nurse cells again.
So this is kind of the process.
And it's happening with
different kinds of cells
throughout the body.
And because I'm a neurologist,
I focus on the brain.
OK.
So what could cause the
cell danger response?
What could trigger that?
There's a whole
lot of things that
are different in our bodies
that start from preconception,
really.
But let's say we're talking
about our microbiome, so
our flora.
And the microbiome
is in the gut.
It's also on the skin.
It's also in our
nasal passageways.
There's a lot of different
microbiomes in our body.
So that can be
affected by, let's say,
how we were born-- c-section
versus vaginal delivery.
Formula feeding
versus breastfeeding.
All of these things
influence our microbiome.
And our microbiome is
influencing our immune system.
And our immune system is
influencing this cell danger
response.
Chronic use of antibiotics.
So recently a study
came out that showed
that one round of antibiotics
can change your microbiome
for an entire year.
So that-- if we
think about, let's
say, those people who
got a lot of bronchitis,
let's say, or the kids who
are getting ear infections all
the time, getting three rounds
of antibiotics a year, four.
A lot of people will come to me
and they'll say, oh, you know.
I say, well, so has your child
ever been on antibiotics?
And they say, oh, no
more than anyone else.
Well, how many times?
Oh, maybe five times a year.
I'm like, what if I told
you some people never
are on antibiotics?
Maybe that's not so normal.
That's affecting the microbiome.
Things like acetaminophen,
Tylenol, ibuprofen, steroids,
all of those things
are impacting it.
Vaccines and other
pharmaceuticals
are always influencing
microbiome,
even ones that we don't think--
like certain pharmaceuticals
that we wouldn't
imagine necessarily
are influencing the microbiome,
like certain mood stabilizers,
can actually do that.
And sometimes that
can be why they're
associated with weight gain.
Processed food, pesticides,
and then too much time
indoors, because that actually
does influence our microbiome,
as you'll see.
So this is kind of a little
bit our terrain right now.
And it's a little
different, let's say,
than it was when I was a kid.
Very different than when
my parents were kids.
And our current health
paradigm is really
this-- avoid, avoid,
avoid, avoid, avoid.
Whatever it is, you
should avoid it.
Don't get dirty.
Don't get out there.
We need to protect
ourselves from everything,
everything dirty.
And so I just like to put
this slide in because I think
it really tells us something.
We can't fight nature.
We are nature.
So if we're fighting
it, then it's
going to be-- we're in trouble.
And we need to start
getting into this paradigm
because the paradigm
we're in right now
is actually not
making us healthier.
Partly this is because our
bodies crave complexity.
We think there's some
kind of magic bullet.
We were led to believe it
was pharmaceuticals that were
going to be the magic bullet.
I'm not saying I'm not thankful
that we have pharmaceuticals.
I think they have a place.
There have been times
I've praised God that we
had x, y, or z pharmaceuticals.
So it's not that.
But we are very
reliant on that instead
of looking at what really
the magic bullet is,
which is biodiversity.
And I want to talk about
that a little bit more.
So our nutrition
and our stressors
really come from our terrain.
And so I want to take that
moment to say what is terrain.
And I-- well, terrain
is really many things.
But one of the big things
I think it is, is dirt.
And I kind of use dirt as a
way to talk about terrain.
And dirt is three main things.
It's germs and microbes.
It's fresh food
from healthy soil.
And it's time in nature.
So let's talk about
germs and microbes.
We all know about
germ theory, right?
Our old friend Louis Pasteur,
father of pasteurization,
said diseases are caused
by microorganisms.
These small organisms, too small
to see without magnification,
invade humans, animals,
and other living hosts.
Their growth and reproduction
within their hosts
can cause a disease.
We are sitting ducks.
Something will invade
us, it will make us sick,
and we could die.
And when the whole
germ theory came out,
it was so-- people
became so frightened
of germs that actually
even fermented
foods which were traditionally
eaten-- even yogurt,
even sourdough bread-- was
considered contaminated.
And it was sort of
pushed aside because they
thought, well, germs, bad.
Contamination.
Louis Pasteur actually
had a colleague
at the same time
named Claude Bernard.
And he actually
had a different--
they were kind of, I would
say, friendly competitors,
or "frenemies," as
my tween would say.
And he had this idea that
he called cellular theory.
He said, "Most
microbial diseases
are caused by organisms
present in the body
of a normal individual.
And they become the
cause of disease
when a disturbance
arises which upsets
the equilibrium of the body."
Well, from everything
we're learning--
and I'm going to get into
this a little bit more--
this actually may
have real merit.
And so I call this
the terrain theory.
And the story goes that
at the end of his life,
Louis Pasteur actually said
that his colleague was right.
He said, it's not the microbe.
It's the terrain.
The microbe is nothing.
That's what he said.
So now our paradigm
is starting to change.
Probiotics.
Does anyone here
take probiotics?
You don't have to disclose
if you don't want to.
But can you imagine, let's
say, 10, 15 years ago,
if you would have
said to your doctor,
I'm going to take bacteria on
purpose in a pill every day.
They would have been
like, you're nuts.
Now they're saying,
hey, take probiotics.
Saccharomyces
boulardi is a yeast.
It's a probiotic
yeast which is used
to treat clostridium
difficile, C-diff,
which can be a deadly
infection that can
be resistant to antibiotics.
There's a microvirome
and oncolytic viruses.
I'm going to talk
about that in a minute.
So it's not just the bacteria,
but it's also the viruses.
Soil-based organisms
are now a thing.
We're actually looking now at
soil for the next antibiotics
that are going to not become
resistant, essentially,
because they're
organisms themselves.
Fecal microbial transplant,
has anyone heard of that?
It's been in the papers.
This is happening
in academic centers.
We are giving people
other people's stool.
We're stepping out of
the avoid, avoid, avoid.
We're finally starting
to understand maybe
that's not going to work.
And actually, maybe
you've also seen recently
in the paper vaginal
microbial transfer, which
is being done in
hospitals for babies
that are born by c-section.
Now, there's so
much more than just
having a little
swab of fluid going
into the mouth of the
baby, but it's something.
Because what we're
doing is we're
recognizing that
what we've been doing
might not be helping
for optimal health,
and may be even contributing
to chronic illness.
So I said biodiversity.
And what does that mean, and
why do I say it's important?
So has everyone heard of
the hygiene hypothesis?
The hygiene hypothesis basically
said kids who grew up on farms
are less allergic than
kids who grow up in cities.
And they said, well,
it's because they're
exposed to germs.
And so some researchers
went and said,
OK, we're going to measure
the number of microbes
in an urban apartment and
we're going to compare it
to microbes on a farm.
And what do you
think they found?
The number of organisms
were about equal.
So it wasn't that different.
But the variety on the farm
was very, very diverse.
And there were many
fewer kinds of organisms
in the urban apartment.
So this idea actually
that high diversity
is what actually helps
reduce the risk of asthma,
allergic disease,
autoimmune disease.
And so this is actually
now really kind
of a biodiversity hypothesis.
It's not exactly the
hygiene hypothesis.
Well, what about viruses?
Because, OK, we know
about bacteria being good.
We've got the probiotics,
all of that stuff.
But what about viruses?
Those are bad, right?
Well there was actually this
fantastic paper that came out
in "Nature" at the end of 2014.
And it was talking
about something
called murine norovirus,
which was given
to mice that were germ free.
So they basically sterilize
the mice as best they can.
And we know that when
you get antibiotics,
and you're germ
free, it actually
disrupts the way your
digestive tract functions.
So you have-- your gut is
a little bit of a mess.
Your immune system is disrupted.
A lot of things change.
Well, in the mice that got this
virus-- were given or exposed
to this virus-- the
viruses actually took
over for the bacteria
completely as
if there was no
disruption at all.
So these viruses
mimicked the effect
of the commensal
bacteria of the gut.
And so that actually
kind of gives us
this idea of this
microvirome, like what
are all the things
we're doing, how does
that affect the microvirome?
And then we kind of have this
new literature coming out
about the relationship
between viruses and cancer.
So what we've
thought as doctors--
what I learned in
my training-- is
that certain viruses
actually can put you
at a higher risk for cancer.
Now what we're learning is
that certain viruses actually
are protective.
So for instance, there
are a few papers now
out about mumps and the risk of
developing ovarian cancer later
in life.
So if you had mumps
as a child, you
have half the risk of
developing ovarian cancer.
That's pretty--
And at first it seemed
like an association.
Maybe it's just kind of random.
Maybe it's-- it could
have been a lot of things.
But they actually found that
there are certain proteins that
are different if you
had the mumps that
are circulating for life.
So it's not just random.
There are actually some better--
there's better data now.
And we're also learning
about measles virus,
which acts as an oncolytic.
So difficult to treat
cancers are now-- they're
now exploring measles, injecting
measles into these cancers,
like glioblastoma
multiforme, which
is very difficult to
treat, pancreatic cancer,
another very difficult
to treat cancer.
And in many cases, measles
seems to have an impact.
Now, I mean, again, is
this the be all end all?
No, of course not.
But what we're learning is
it changes the immune system.
And actually just
yesterday a new paper
came out about chicken pox.
And having chicken
pox reduced the risk
of developing gliomas,
another kind of brain tumor,
by more than 20%.
And the authors of the
study said this does not
seem to be random.
It seems very clear.
In fact, the people
who had chicken pox who
did develop gliomas had a
much less aggressive glioma
and had a better course.
So we have to let the juices
flow here and think, what
does it mean, getting dirty?
What does it mean,
getting germy?
What is really
best for our health
and how do we look
at the whole picture?
Parasites.
So pretty unequivocally,
nobody is really
too interested in
getting worms, right?
No one wants that.
But what if I told you
that in populations
who have endemic helminths--
parasitic worms--
they actually have
a much lower risk
of developing type 2 diabetes.
And that also goes
for type 1 diabetes.
So there's an association.
The top of that slide
is where there's
a high incidence
of type 1 diabetes
and the bottom map is where
there's a high risk of having
endemic parasites.
And so diabetes is
much more common
where there's no
endemic helminths.
So now actually one
of the treatments
I didn't put on my
list before is actually
that we're infecting--
experimentally
infecting people with
autoimmune conditions
with parasites as a treatment.
And that is looking
to be quite effective
in certain conditions.
And everything from
inflammatory bowel disease,
to celiac, to type 1
diabetes, even asthma,
there's research going on
right now on this idea.
And here, a paper,
"The emerging role
of helminths in the treatment of
inflammatory bowel disorders."
And what they say--
because I just
thought this was fascinating--
in the end of the paper
is the relationship between
humans and nematodes
of the gastrointestinal
tract can
be considered as
a mutualism rather
than a typical parasitism.
So maybe we should be
friends with our microbes
instead of being at war.
And maybe we should be thinking
more about our resilient health
rather than avoid,
avoid, avoid, avoid.
Attack, attack, attack.
And this is really a
different paradigm.
And here's just a paper looking
at the experimental hookworm
infection in people
who have celiac.
So what was really
interesting, I
thought, from this
paper was actually
that the people who had the
experimental hookworm infection
had a tremendous increase
in diversity of microbes.
They had a much
richer microbiome when
they had helminth infection.
So and that seems to really
regulate the immune system.
And if you think
about it, in a lot
of these conditions--
autoimmune conditions,
for instance, or allergic
conditions-- a lot of times
people are getting frequent
rounds of antibiotics
because their immune
systems are so dysregulated.
And actually what
we may be doing
is creating more of
a destructive pathway
rather than a
regenerative pathway.
OK, let's move to a
cheerful topic of food
coming from healthy soil.
So again, fresh food
from healthy soil.
That is about biodiversity.
And what we've learned is
that our diet-- the diversity
of our diet influences also the
diversity of our microbiome.
Not so surprising.
Food is the embodiment
of our terrain.
We eat animals and plants.
Animals live on plants.
And plants live on soil,
sun, water, and rocks.
And we basically
ingest all of that.
There are also the microbes.
Plants actually have their
own microbiome, as do animals.
And mycorrhizae, which
live along the roots
and connect-- they're sort
of the plant internet--
that connects all
the plants so they
can communicate with
each other and act
as community, essentially,
even though they're non-mobile.
So they can't come
be together so well,
but they can communicate
with each other.
And actually the
mycorrhizae also
help with nutrition for
the plants and so on.
So when we're eating, we're
really part of this community.
And we're really
internalizing that community
to become part of
our own bodies.
So nutritional
depletion makes us
vulnerable to chronic illness.
So we talked about
avoid, avoid, avoid.
Well, depletion is-- when we're
talking about that resilient
body, and we're talking
about the terrain theory,
remember it's really
not the microbe.
It's the terrain.
We need that
nutritional richness.
So nutrient density
is kind of the theme.
What I do if a patient
comes to my office, whatever
their problem is, and
however severe it is,
people are often shocked.
Let's say a kid is coming
in with a lot of seizures.
And it's not to say I'm
not going to do something
about the symptoms.
But at the same
time, there's no way
that I'm going to be able to
really heal or reverse illness
if the person is not
nourished and they don't have
the tools within their bodies.
So even if you're
giving medication,
people respond much
better when they're
eating nutrient-dense food.
And of course, they have
to be able to absorb it,
so you need to know a
little bit about gut health.
But the first thing is
what are you eating.
So reserve is key.
And nourishment
really equals reserve.
A nutrient density
creates the resilience.
So we have to think really
about quality of food.
We're thinking about
the macronutrient.
We're thinking about where
it's grown, how it's grown.
What happens when it's grown?
What kind of chemicals
are being put on it?
How is that affecting the
microbiome of the soil?
microbiome of the plants?
What happens after it's grown?
How is it processed?
So one thing we know for
instance about wheat.
A lot of people
talk about gluten.
Gluten bothers them.
Is it really all gluten?
Well, we don't know.
But what we do know is that
wheat is sprayed pretty heavily
with Roundup right
before it's harvested
because it's a drying agent and
it essentially creates a better
harvest because the
seeds are released.
And then that basically
is then taken off
and becomes our flour and
the wheat that we're eating,
and it just had this
application of a chemical which
impacts our microbiome,
impacts our health.
So these are questions.
Because it's not obvious
when you look at bread,
what happened before
the wheat came.
And that's why it's not
just a hipster thing
to say where did
this food come from.
It's a very real issue which,
until not that long ago,
we all really cared
about and knew.
Well, we cared, but
it really didn't
matter because our
food came from nearby.
Now it's very different.
And how quickly is it eaten?
That's actually
part of it, as well.
And how is it prepared?
So for instance, some people
have a hard time tolerating
grains, or beans, or nuts.
So soaking them, sprouting
them, or fermenting them
can actually-- which
is traditionally
how people ate those
kinds of things, the seed
family of food-- actually
makes it much more
nutrient dense for us.
Because seeds are intended to
survive our intestinal tract.
Because really, things
like grain, or nuts,
or whatever are plants
wanting to reproduce.
And so they have a
lot of different kinds
of compounds that protect
them from our digestive tract.
And we're the animals that are
supposed to eat them and then
walk somewhere, and
in our scat leave them
somewhere so they can grow.
That's not happening
so much right now.
But that's really the idea.
And that's why it's hard for
us to break everything down,
because we're not intended
to be able to do it.
So we have to do it through
the way we prepare it.
And nutrition is
all of these things.
It's the macronutrients.
It's the micronutrients.
It's phytonutrients, as well.
All the things that make
plants different colors
are actually the phytonutrients.
Microbes, stem
cells, pheromones,
and little traces of soil.
If you go to the
farmer's market,
for instance, maybe
you're not going
to get that highly
power-washed stuff.
Maybe you're going to see
there's a little dirt still
attached to your food.
And you might rinse it off,
but there's going to be a film.
There's going to be a trace.
And that's part of your
daily probiotic, basically.
It's the best
probiotic in a sense.
So eating real food is
critically important.
And I like to always
start with the things
that we've been told
not to eat, like eggs.
Now they're kind of
coming back into favor.
This is how my eggs look
because I keep chickens.
I live in New York City,
but I have a little yard.
And I keep chickens, and we
get fresh multi-colored eggs,
which is pretty fun.
And these are how
the egg yolks look.
And that is because they
have lutein and zeaxanthin
in them, which actually
protect our eyes, our maculas,
and also protect us
from colon cancer,
particularly for young people.
It also has vitamin D because
if the chickens are outside.
So they're a great
source of vitamin D,
which most food is not.
Because if you keep
animals indoors,
then they don't have vitamin
D in their eggs, or milk,
or what have you.
And choline, which I'll talk
about in a couple minutes.
Cholesterol.
Eggs are a great
source of cholesterol.
This is a good thing,
not a bad thing.
Cholesterol are actually what
make our cell membranes have
structure because
they create stiffness,
whereas the omega-3s
and omega-6s actually
create fluidity.
And you need to have a
balance of those two things
in order to have a
healthy cell membrane.
You also need cholesterol
for brain development,
particularly in babies,
but actually not only.
And we're finding that
one of the biggest side
effects of all these cholesterol
medications that people
are taking is cognitive
dysfunction, actually.
And so what we're learning
is that cholesterol is
really important for the brain.
It's so rich in mother's
milk and so important
that there are actually
special enzymes that
aid the digestive tract
in absorbing cholesterol
in the baby from
the mother's milk.
And we find that
cholesterol levels
are lower in people have autism
spectrum disorder, people
who have depression, in
people have violent behavior,
and even people who
are suicide completers.
So low cholesterol, actually,
in a very large meta-analysis
predicted an increased
risk of dying
from gastrointestinal
respiratory illness.
So it seems to be that
cholesterol actually
has a very powerful effect
on immune enhancement.
And in fact, it actually--
having high cholesterol
does not-- unless
you have diabetes,
that is actually
the one case where
cholesterol can be problematic.
But if you do not have diabetes,
then having higher cholesterol
is associated with a
lower risk of mortality.
Choline I want to just
mention because it's sort
of like the forgotten cousin.
But it's very high in egg
yolks, as well as in liver.
And it's very important for
brain development, as well.
So in pregnant rats
that were given choline,
they actually had very
improved cognitive function
when they were born.
And it was so impressive
that even when
they were elderly rats,
the researchers could still
tell which animals had been
getting choline in utero.
That's pretty impressive.
And it's also just
something we all really need
in terms of brain function,
in terms of detoxification,
and other things.
And then of course
we all, I think,
know about the essential
fatty acids like omega-3's.
We hear a lot about it.
Hey, it doesn't have
to just be from fish.
It can also be from
eggs, especially
from animals, or milk,
or meat, animals that
have been living on pasture.
So lower risk of ADD, cancer,
learning disabilities,
mental illness,
seizures, asthma.
There is a long, long list of
how these essential fatty acids
are important for our
bodies and brains.
And it comes from what we eat.
I mean, that's
really the upshot.
Raw dairy products I
like to always mention,
because it's pretty taboo.
And yet there have been
a couple of studies
on unboiled milk--
not in this country,
because it really
would be hard to do.
It would be hard to get past
our IRBs in the hospitals.
But there is both the PASTURE
study and the GABRIELA study,
which looked at infection.
The first one
looked at infection.
So babies or little kids
that drank unboiled milk,
how did that impact
their health?
Well, actually they
had fewer fevers.
They had fewer ear infections
and fewer respiratory
infections.
So that was actually-- and they
had fewer inflammatory markers,
as well.
And in the other
study, it actually
showed less hay fever,
less asthma, less allergy.
It's thought that
this is-- I thought
it was going to be
about the microbiome,
and that when we
pasteurize milk, maybe
it impacts bacteria.
And that may be a
part of it, as well.
But what they found is that
pasteurization actually
impacts the whey protein,
and that whey protein
seems to modulate our
immune systems differently.
So I see lots, and lots, and
lots of people who cannot
tolerate dairy.
And I don't think
that-- I'm not someone
who thinks that cow's milk
is only for baby cows,
because we have
subsisted on dairy
forever, before we
were even really doing
formal agriculture.
Even as nomads, we subsisted
on different kinds of dairy.
But first of all,
how was it drunk?
And second of all,
it was different,
straight from the udder,
a little bit different.
Eating organic food--
is organic healthier?
Is it a hipster thing?
Is it a fad?
I actually think eating organic
is critically important,
because first of all,
calculations of safety
are for each food, but not
averaged over many foods.
And we don't know
what people are
eating, particularly children.
Because children
actually are exposed
to more pesticides
per body weight
because they eat more
fruit and vegetables,
generally, per body weight
than we do as adults.
And a lot of it is
concentrated in fat.
There are very
interesting studies
about Parkinson's and pesticides
and other neurologic illnesses.
But in addition to
that, this is a study
that was done in
a Mexican farming
population, where the
people in the valley
were using pesticides.
And the people who didn't
want to use pesticides
from this same community
moved to the foothills.
So you see that-- and
then a psychologist
came and evaluated
their development.
And this is one of the
developmental tests
that was published.
I really think of this
as a landmark study
because this is one of
the developmental tests we
do in children to see
how they're developing,
how do they draw a person.
And you can see in
an age-matched way
that the children who were
in the foothills-- that's
no pesticides-- had these
beautiful people, looked
much more like people than
the children of the same age
or older in the valley.
And in that case,
they were actually
much more scribbled,
didn't really
look so much like people.
There was really a pattern
of developmental delay.
And so pesticides
do have an impact.
We know that organic
diets significantly lower
dietary exposure to pesticides.
This has actually been
looked at in several studies.
So we look at the
urine, and we look
at metabolites of these
pesticides in the urine,
and the levels are lower.
And we know that ADHD is higher.
The risk of ADHD is
higher, actually double,
in children-- in this study
it was looking at over 1,100
children-- who had higher
levels of these organophosphate
pesticide metabolites.
OK, eating plants.
This sounds obvious, right?
Yes, eat your fruit
and vegetables.
But there's really
great science behind it.
And we again want
that biodiversity
that I talked about before.
You want a rainbow
on your plate.
Turns out my mom was right when
she said that when I was a kid.
And part of it is because
of the phytonutrients
that make all those
different colors.
Phytonutrients actually
interact with everything
from our cell membranes
and our organ systems
to our actual DNA.
And they are in conversation
with our bodies all the time.
One of my favorite
phytonutrients to talk about
are actually the
bitter compounds.
Anyone here ever use
bitters, bitter tonic?
They're amazing.
Really if you want something--
speaking of magic bullets,
this is one of those things that
influences increasing stomach
acid, which helps digest better.
Increases motility, so bloating,
burping, constipation, gas,
all those things improve.
Help with boosting the immune
system of the digestive tract,
so it helps protect you
from the gastroenteritis
and those things that you don't
want to get in the wintertime.
Actually interacts with your
liver to boost detoxification.
Interacts with your pancreas
so that your blood sugar
stays more stable.
And boosts your immune system,
even in your ear, nose, throat,
and lungs, to help protect you
from whatever cold and flu is
coming your way.
Bitters are even being looked
at as a treatment for asthma
because it helps
bronchodilation.
This happens partly because why?
What do bitters
remind our body of?
Poison.
So our bodies get
really like, stand up.
OK, we need to take
care of a lot of things,
and be really good at
it, and be efficient.
And so a bitter tonic, there's
a favorite bitter tonic
many people like.
So only a couple of you
raised your hand when I said,
anyone use bitter tonic?
But does anyone
here like coffee?
No?
Yeah.
OK.
That's part of, I
think, the craving
that people have for coffee.
It's not just about
caffeine, but it's
about the bitter
compounds in there.
And they actually
have a very-- you've
heard people say, oh, if I don't
have my coffee, I can't poop.
So that's part of what
the bitters are doing.
Beer, anyone here like beer?
So that's another bitter
tonic because of the hops.
And dark chocolate-- someone
asked me about chocolate
before I started and said,
my kids love chocolate.
Dark chocolate is a bitter.
It doesn't have too
much sugar, and cacao
is a bitter, a bitter tonic.
And you can make hot chocolate
very lightly sweetened.
Get yourself or your
kids used to that
and that can be
their bitter tonic.
Peel of fruits and
vegetables also
have bitter components to
them, and the leafy greens,
all of that.
You don't have to be eating
broccoli rabe or dandelion
greens every day.
Chamomile tea is another bitter.
Fermented foods, OK, we
want to be constantly--
we want the soil, but we also
want the fermented foods, which
just help us mind our microbes.
OK, a word about
sugar because it's
a topic that we
hear a lot about,
and it's pretty demonized.
So I do want to say
that sugar, there's
a lot we could say about it.
And I really talk about it
in great detail in my book.
But one of the things
that sugar does do
is it stimulates insulin.
I mean, so that makes
sense because we
have to manage the sugar.
And insulin is actually
a pro-inflammatory.
So sometimes people
will come and say
oh, my kid, when they eat
sugar, they start to act crazy.
Or people will say when I eat
sugar, I feel really mean,
or I feel really angry.
And they're told, no,
that can't be true.
Actually, yes,
because when you have
that pro-inflammatory
cascade happening,
it influences the way
your brain functions.
And basically having
a big spike in insulin
in some sensitive
people can really
influence their behavior
and other things, too.
Some people will feel more pain.
They have pain issues.
They might be more in
pain when they have it.
Part of it is the
way insulin actually
stimulates this enzyme called
phospholipase A2, which
helps to basically
dissolve your cell
membrane, fats in
your cell membrane.
And that is obviously
not a great thing.
But what about honey?
What about a natural sugar?
So honey actually,
interestingly,
is being looked at now as a
treatment for type 1 diabetes.
Why?
Because it stabilizes blood
sugar levels and insulin
levels.
So I actually--
obviously this is
something to do in moderation.
I'm not saying let's all go
out and start drinking honey,
because all sweets
are really not things
that we-- if you've ever
gone maple sugaring,
does anyone know how much?
I mean, it takes
a lot of the sap
in order to make a little
container of maple syrup.
So we're not intended to
get tons and tons of sugar
in our diet.
But if you're going
to have sweeteners,
raw honey is fantastic.
It actually has
wound-healing benefits,
immune-regulating
benefits, and it actually
stabilizes the blood sugar.
Blackstrap molasses is
one of my favorite things
because it's actually
higher in antioxidants
than several containers
of blueberries.
Molasses is the leftovers
when we extract sugar
from sugar cane.
Everything that's left becomes
this soupy, sticky, thick
conglomeration,
which is molasses.
And it's really high in iron.
It's high in antioxidants.
It's high in a lot of minerals.
And it is one of
the best ways I've
found to treat constipation
in kids, actually,
and in everyone.
You just take a teaspoon a day
of the blackstrap molasses.
And it's a great source
of digestible iron.
All right, last
category, time in nature.
So everything's connected.
We've got our microbial health,
which affects our soil health.
Soil health affects
plant health.
Plant health affects
animal health.
And plant and animal health
affects human health.
And soil health
So soil organisms
actually make us happy.
There are several studies on
this Mycobacterium vaccae,
which is a soil organism.
And it's been looked at
in cancer patients, where
it actually improved
emotional health, vitality,
and cognitive function.
It improved cognition
in another study,
where it lowered
their stress levels
and made them more relaxed.
And that actually is because
Mycobacterium vaccae actually
increases serotonin levels as
if the animal or the person
was getting an SSRI,
like a anti-depressant.
That's how much it boosts
our serotonin levels.
And these soil organisms
even can improve cognition.
So in Mycobacterium
vaccae mice were
navigating a difficult
maze twice as fast
and with half the
anxiety of the ones that
did not get the exposure.
And we need the constant
exposure, because in these mice
this "superhero effect,"
as they called it,
lasted only for three weeks.
What about sunshine?
Well, there's this epidemic
of near-sightedness going on.
We all kind of
thought it's genetic.
It turns out that it's
actually so severe in Korea
right now that 97% of
young men are near-sighted.
And that's considered
epidemic levels.
Well, turns out, by
accident it was discovered
that being exposed to
sunlight, natural light,
seems to reverse that effect.
So what is happening to all
of us and all of the kids
who are sitting inside
looking at screens all day?
We're not getting so
much natural light,
and it's actually impacting
vision development.
Not only that, but in a
study-- and this study
is being mined and mined because
just another aspect of it
was just released
a few weeks ago.
But this study
looked at, in Sweden,
at 30,000 women over 20 years
and found that women who
assiduously avoided sun exposure
were twice as likely to die
as those who didn't.
It just came out recently.
They said this is actually akin
to the risk of being a smoker,
avoiding the sun.
And in people who did get
skin cancer, by the way,
of those women, the ones
who were exposed to the sun
had less aggressive cancer.
Easier to treat
Nature enhances healing.
So when rooms overlook
trees in hospitals,
patients have shorter
post-operative hospital stays,
lower scores for complications,
fewer negative comments
in the nurse's notes-- we
all want that-- and less
need for strong analgesics.
Nature also reduces
pain and anxiety.
So exposure to nature can lower
heart rate and self-reports
of emotional distress.
Patients felt
calmer on days there
was a mural of a natural
scene on the wall than when
the wall was blank.
And nature in several
studies-- and some of them
are in children and many of
them also in adults-- actually,
so children who play
on natural playgrounds
had fewer attention
and cognitive issues.
Their concentration was better.
Their cognitive and physical
functioning was better.
And test performance was better.
Has anyone here heard of
shinrin-yoku, forest bathing?
So this is very much a part
of the culture in Japan.
And it's immersing
yourself in the forest.
And a lot of studies
have been done on this
because it's actually used as
preventive medicine, where they
actually get a
prescription to go
spend more time in the forest.
And not only does it improve
cognition, improve focus,
improve sleep, lower
levels of cortisol,
which are the stress
hormones, and so on.
But actually, it boosted
natural killer cell function,
so it helped the immune
system to function better,
and improved the number
of anti-cancer proteins
circulating.
So it helps protect
us from cancer,
just by being in the forest.
So dirt, eat it.
Try to get organic or
biodynamic produce.
Try to avoid
power-washed vegetables.
Cook your food with peels, or
eat it with peels if you can.
Grow food in it.
Eat plants that were
grown in healthy soil.
And only eat animal
products and meat
from animals that lived
on pasture, lived outside.
Nourish your soil.
So composting, mulching,
no chemical fertilizers
and pesticides if
you can avoid it.
Bathe in it.
Get dirty.
Go make some mud pies.
I don't care how old you are.
If you need a kid, find
a kid to do it with.
But getting dirty
is really important.
And it's pretty obvious, right?
Try to grow a little food.
I don't care if
you're in an apartment
and you have a
little pot of herbs
so you can have
your own fresh food.
Or go to your farmer's
markets or join a CSA.
Keep chickens.
It's not that hard to do.
Go to community gardens if
you don't have your own space.
Go foraging.
I started doing this last year.
I found like 30 pounds
of maitake mushrooms
in the New York City
park right near me.
If I want to sell that--
no. [CHUCKLES] But I ate it.
It was amazing.
Cooking together, eating
together, and getting outside.
So our choice is
between this and this.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm happy to take
questions if anyone has any.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
food allergies.
And I saw a study said that a
lot of common food allergies,
like eggs and peanuts, that
those substances are substrates
for growing vaccines.
But I haven't seen any
other confirmation of that.
I don't know if you've heard
of anything besides the one.
MAYA SHETREAT-KLEIN: It's
true that some of those
can be used as
substrates in growing
certain aspects of vaccines.
There is data also that shows
that probably the aluminum
seems to, because it's
given as an adjuvant-- which
is on purpose to stimulate the
immune system because you want
it to respond to whatever
the antigen is, whatever
it may be-- pertussis,
or measles, or whatever.
Actually, those adjuvants
seem to increase the risk
of developing food allergies.
So particularly when people are
getting-- children particularly
are getting their
vaccines-- one of the things
that I outline in the
book is that giving foods,
we're introducing a lot of
new foods at the same time.
And those vaccines
actually are designed
to make the body
much more allergic.
And because children are getting
a lot of them all at one time,
it may prime the body
to become more allergic.
So that may be an element.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Yeah, I have two questions.
One, maybe building
on that a little bit,
on allergies or
food sensitivities.
Do you have any
thoughts or advice
on the issue of babies being
born with different food
sensitivities?
And then the second
question is, realistically,
how do we get raw milk into
our diets or our kids' diets?
MAYA SHETREAT-KLEIN: So babies
being born with them really
has a lot to do with
what's happening in utero
and what's happening at birth.
So definitely everything
from-- because babies
are born with what we
would call leaky guts.
That used to be an
alternative medicine term,
but now it's not anymore.
We just call it increased
gut permeability.
That's the science term.
But basically it's
normal to have that.
And because of a lot of things
that we're doing-- maybe
because of adjuvants, maybe
because of how babies are born,
and maybe our own, as
the people giving birth,
microbiomes might be
a little disrupted--
it can put certain babies more
at risk for developing food
allergies.
So part of what I
recommend, if possible, is
to breastfeed, if possible,
is to do probiotics.
And there are infant probiotics
that are designed specifically
for babies.
And as far as the raw milk
goes, there are ways to get it.
It's state by state.
I definitely recommend raw
milk should be state-certified
because you want to
know-- I personally
visit any farm that I
would get raw milk from.
I wouldn't just get it from
a random place and drink it.
I think it's important to
know where it's coming from
and I want to know that
it's state-certified
because you can
check for any kind
of significant contamination.
But there are websites
that can connect you
with raw milk producers.
A lot of Amish farmers will
go all around the east coast,
as well.
So I'm happy to connect you
with some of those resources.
AUDIENCE: One quick follow up.
Does raw milk cheese give
you the same benefits?
Because that's more
readily available.
MAYA SHETREAT-KLEIN:
In certain ways, yes.
In certain ways, yes,
because it was never
pasteurized, so you're
avoiding, hopefully,
most of the organisms
that could be an issue,
but without changing the way.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: What's your take
in general on vaccinations?
Because you mentioned
measles and mumps
might have positive benefits.
But I'd rather not
get measles and mumps
when I'm too old, so I need
to be vaccinated at one point.
Are you basically saying
that kids shouldn't
be vaccinated that early?
But then child mortality
with those diseases
is a problem, as well.
So I'm a bit confused.
What are you trying to say?
MAYA SHETREAT-KLEIN:
I think what
I'm saying is that we don't
get something for nothing.
And that we really
need to look at-- we
need to study this because
I think previously we
thought of everything infectious
as being contamination
and totally negative.
So the question
is, how can we gain
those ben-- do we gain
those kinds of benefits
being vaccinated?
It's not clear.
And what can we do
if we're leading--
if we're doing this medical
intervention on 100% of people,
essentially, that might be
disrupting their immune health
or their gut health in some way
and putting them more at risk.
So this is something,
I think, that we
need to really study carefully.
And it's not really
being studied.
AUDIENCE: My
understanding always
was that being
vaccinated basically
causes the same immune
response from the body
as if you were actually
having those viruses.
MAYA SHETREAT-KLEIN: It's
not exactly the same.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
MAYA SHETREAT-KLEIN:
It can approximate,
but it's not exactly the same.
And like I said, we just haven't
been-- this is new science.
I mean, almost all
of those papers
are things that came out
over the past few years.
So this is something
that we're really
going to need to
carefully investigate
to see essentially what the
impact is of vaccination.
Do we get that same
benefit or not, and what
is the long-term effect?
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I suspect there's a lot
of special interests
who aren't exactly thrilled with
the message you're discovering.
Have you gotten any
interesting reactions, you
or the other researchers who
are working in this field,
to some of the major
pharmaceutical and agricultural
practitioners?
MAYA SHETREAT-KLEIN: I
think their strategy,
as much as possible, is to kind
of black out what's happening.
So the less attention
gotten, the better.
And I've definitely heard
from some of the other media
opportunities.
They've said, oh, we're
really interested.
And then I've heard back, our
sponsors wouldn't like it.
So I think that's
their primary approach.
And I do think that there are
a lot of corporate interests
that are not in favor
of the kind of science
that is being done now.
AUDIENCE: And what about
standard medical training?
Are doctors opening up to this?
MAYA SHETREAT-KLEIN: I
think to some degree.
It depends on the doctors.
But I think there are definitely
doctors who are open to it
if we're looking at the
science in a critical way.
I mean, I think raw milk
is very ingrained as being
a terrible thing in doctors,
so that's a tough one.
And I also talk
quite a bit-- I have
a whole section on fluoride.
And that's another thing
that-- doing fluoridated water
is another thing that's really,
really difficult for doctors
to wrap their heads around.
But in other ways, I
think they're open.
I mean, it depends.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Do you have any
thoughts on being vegan?
You mentioned plants
and animals a lot.
And is there a
right way to do it,
or is it just very difficult?
MAYA SHETREAT-KLEIN: I think
that children probably should
really not be vegan ever.
Or it would be really,
really difficult to do well.
Vegetarian has to also
be really careful.
But at least-- the thing is that
animal products are very, very
nutrient dense and
have certain properties
that the quality is different.
Protein is not protein,
is not protein.
That said, do I
think being vegan can
be good for some people?
Sure.
Especially because
I don't necessarily
think that we have
to adhere to one diet
our whole entire lives.
I was a vegetarian,
actually, for many years.
And then at a certain
point in time,
my body kind of screamed
and didn't like it.
And then I ate meat and
that was better for me.
But obviously, the way I
eat meat, as I talk about,
is doing it, I
think, differently
than a lot of people.
But I think what's
really important is
to listen to your body.
So for instance,
I've had patients
who have come to me that were
vegan or strict vegetarian
and they were really sick.
And when I told them
to-- one of my patients,
when I told her I thought she
should eat meat, she cried.
I mean, she was
really angry with me.
She actually stopped
coming to me,
but I happen to know
her socially, as well.
So five years later,
she came to me
and she had a significant
autoimmune disease.
And she said, I've started
having meat once a week
and I feel amazing.
It's changed me.
My energy is
completely different.
This doesn't have
to be for everyone.
But I do think that
it's important to listen
to your body.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
about the sun exposure.
My father died from melanoma
and my mom is Korean,
so I never go in the sun.
And is it a vitamin D thing?
Would you take vitamin D
pills and that would solve it?
Or is that you really need
to be out in the sunshine?
MAYA SHETREAT-KLEIN:
Yeah, that's
a really important question.
Thank you for asking it.
So number one, the
major danger is sunburn.
So you don't want to burn.
So if you're someone
who burns very quickly,
you have to be very
careful and go out
in the sun at times of day where
it's not very, very strong.
You do want that sun exposure.
And it's not clear that
it's just vitamin D. Vitamin
D is an element.
But sun, again, we like to
really simplify and reduce
things to, go outside and get
your vitamin D. It's probably
more than that.
But what the literature actually
shows is that chronic sun
exposure, a little bit of
chronic sun exposure every day
is protective from
developing melanoma.
So a little bit each day.
I do know some people who
say, when I go out in the sun,
I feel sick.
I feel terrible.
I think, again, listening to
your body is really important.
But I do think getting
some sun is important.
It just depends on how
much and what time of day
so that you're protecting
yourself and covering up
at times of day that are strong,
or just staying out of the sun.
Thank you so much, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]